[Musique]
adossé à la voie ferrée l'édifice rodier
a abrité le magasin baron sport jusqu'en
2010 l'immeuble triangulaires étaient
menacés par le temps et par le projet du
réseau express métropolitains patrimoine
des années 1880 à préserver selon
héritage montréal et qui sera sauvé par
l'homme d'affaires georges coulombe jeu
toujours raymond v des vieux bâtiments
gt gt dans le patrimoine l'ancien
immeuble de la banque royale qui abrite
le clou collective café rue saint
jacques
c'est lui il a une certaine habitude des
mauvaises surprises qui complique
parfois ce genre de travaux la structure
des spasmes arrêt comme ça et l'autre
comme seule structure du bâtiment était
en danger donc fallu faire un sou neuf
complète projette combien ici c'est vrai
entre ce but nous dire pour que la ville
accepte de vendre le bâtiment un peu
moins d'un million de dollars il devait
y avoir un projet low sdl la piscine a
plongé on va réunir ici les
entrepreneurs culturels et créatifs de
tout horizon des arts vivants jusqu'au
jeux vidéo aurait été virtuel
architecture design chez apollo music
store une jeune entreprise montréalaise
qui proposent de la musique aux
entrepreneurs pour leur projet de
publicité ou de marketing a réservé un
espace pour l'été prochain
nous ce qu'on vient chercher ici oui il
ya un bureau certes mais ce qu'on vient
chercher ses plus les échanges avec
d'abord les menteurs les formateurs les
autres entreprises qui peuvent avoir
vécu des expériences qui ressemble à la
note avec lesquels on peut échanger dans
les deux sens tout cela convient bien à
griffin tan cité du multimédia
l'immeuble comportera aussi un
restaurant et une galerie d'art ouverte
au public
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal